donald trump former president donald
trump the man the media still obsesses
over still needs to be the worst man on
earth so that they don't have to look in
the mirror and see that they actually
are the evil ones
he was on sean hannity's program on fox
news last night it was a wide-ranging
interview but i thought this was the
most interesting part donald trump
talking about the media
they are corrupt they are and i say it
and i don't want to say it much
but i say it and i hope in the future i
won't have to they are the enemy of the
people
and we could have a country that would
be able to heal and get together except
the media foments it they're so corrupt
and you know i called it i came up with
the term fake news a long time ago i
don't know if i'll get credit for that
but that's okay the fake news but it's
really the corrupt news it's corrupt
what they do and they're so important it
could be well important they used to
have a high approval rating now they
have the lowest i think they have a
lower rating than
mitch mcconnell which is pretty good i
tell you what they have a rating that
now is people people have gotten wise to
it they've just gotten wise to it
god it will never ever cease to amaze me
that that golden man
with whatever is going on with his hair
is more authentic than virtually every
other politician in america even today
and i put that notwithstanding a couple
of the guys that you know i like like
ted cruz and rand paul and obviously
there's a couple others but
it's just incredible the best part of
that of course is that he still wants
credit for the phrase fake news which is
sort of hilarious like what what do you
want you want an award should they hand
him some sort of golden statue you
donald trump created the term fake news
anyway getting to the to the nuts and
bolts of what he said he said they're
corrupt now that is just obviously true
the mainstream media is evil and corrupt
at one point yesterday i verified it
myself
nowhere at cnn.com was there anything
about the car ramming event in wisconsin
from a couple days ago okay somehow that
was not on cnn's front page
that is a type of fake news when they
will not show you something because it
goes against their narrative that is a
type of fake news fake news is not just
oh headline doesn't match what's in the
article or headlines completely made up
sometimes avoidance of a story is
actually fake news he said that they're
the enemy of the people which i think
was a nod to my buddy michael malus who
has been saying for a long time and i
like to quote him on it the corporate
press is the enemy of the people so he
is right about that he says we have a
country that could come together doesn't
it feel like that like it actually does
if these people were not constantly
meddling if they were not constantly
trying to push you into thinking that
your neighbor is a racist and a bigot
and a nazi and all of these things
and maybe doing a little bit of a better
job honestly reporting what's happening
and not just the things that fit their
narrative and then not hiding the things
that don't fit their narrative don't you
think the country could kind of come
together but there's not a lot of
dollars in that i suppose you know like
i'm not saying i do a perfect job here
and i obviously make fun of the lefties
left and right but i think if you watch
this show you know that one of the
things i'm trying to do is get us to a
place
where where we're a little more decent
where we're a little more thoughtful
where we can heal some of this stuff do
you think that that's what they want
it's so dangerous and this was the
danger you can watch a video that i did
the day after the 2016 election we were
i just moved into my other house we
didn't even have my old studio that you
remember in the garage we didn't even
have that studio yet there was
construction going on i'm sitting there
off my computer in the backyard it's
very loud
day after day after trump got elected
and i did not vote for trump that time
around okay and there's a video of me
still considering myself part of the
left saying hey maybe this is a moment
where if we give this guy a chance
that some good things can happen but if
we keep calling him racist what if it
turns out that he does some good things
what if we don't get into more wars what
if the economy is good what if things
are generally good in the country and
that's pretty much what happened let's
remove covet from it for a sec that's
pretty much what happened but once
you've done that once you've called half
the country nazis and bigots you've
painted yourself into the corner right
it's not what you've done to them all
right you've said mean things about
people people get mean things said about
them all the time right like every time
the new york times or daily beast calls
me a nazi now or whatever they call me
it's like oh glad you guys are still
paying attention to me i suppose but
it's what you're doing to yourself
because you can never be like oh you
know you're not going to believe this
guys that hitler that hitler guy and the
nazis that i've been telling you about
they're actually not so bad
so that's why they always double down
they always double down they just got to
do more and more and more of it but in
any event what trump said there was
correct and the more that the media
crumbles and we know that their ratings
are crumbling and everything else the
more they will become hysterical in
order to keep people paying attention um
but at this point i think you should
basically go on the assumption that if
cnn says something it pretty much is not
true
and and maybe not every specific thing
as i said yesterday it's like if they're
reporting something about a a hurricane
i don't know ballpark i guess they're
probably gonna get it right although
there was that video of anderson cooper
pretending that he was standing in like
you know five feet of water and then you
and then if you zoom out on the shot you
see people like in this much water
behind them so they yeah all right i
tried there you see what i did i tried
to give them the benefit they lie about
everything that's all you need to know